in the art of computer programming you
wrote the real problem is that
programmers have spent far too much time
worrying about efficiency in the wrong
places and at the wrong times
premature optimization is the root of
all evil
in parentheses or at least most of it in
programming
can you uh explain this idea
uh what's the wrong time what is the
wrong place for our optimization so
first of all the word optimization
i i started out writing software uh and
optimization was i was a compiler writer
so optimization meant
making the
uh
making a better translation
so that it would run faster on it on a
machine it's an optimized program it's
just like you know you
you run a program and you set the
optimization level uh for
the compiler so that's one
word for optimization um and at that
time i
i happen to be looking in an unabridged
dictionary
uh for some reason or other and i came
to work optimizes so what's the meaning
of the word optimized and it says to
view with optimism
[Laughter]
and you look in webster's dictionary of
english language in 1960 early 1960s
that's what optimized me meant okay
now
so people
started doing cost optimization other
kinds of things
you know whole subfields of
of
algorithms and economics and whatever
are are based on what they call
optimization now but
but
to me optimization when i was saying
that
was saying
uh changing a program to make it more uh
tuned to the machine
and i found out that
when a person writes a program
uh
he
he or she's
tends to think that
the parts that were hardest to write are
going to be hardest for the computer to
execute
so so
maybe i have 10 pages of code but
i i had to work a week writing this page
i i mentally think that when the
computer gets to that page it's going to
slow down
right
it's because oh i don't understand what
i'm doing i better
be more careful anyway this is of course
silly but it's it's something that we
that we
that we don't know when we write a piece
of code we don't know what
whether the computer is actually
going to be executing that code very
much
so so people had had a very
poor understanding of
of
what the computer was actually doing
i i made one test where
where we studied a fortran compiler
and it was spending more than 80 of its
time reading the comments card
um but as a programmer we were really
concerned about how fast it could take a
complicated expression that had lots of
levels of parenthesis and
and and convert that in
into something
but that was just you know less than one
percent of the uh
so if we optimized that
uh
we didn't know what we were doing but
but but if if we knew that it was
spending 80 percent of his time on the
comments card you know in 10 minutes we
could we could make the
the compiler run more than twice as fast
and you can only do that once you've
completed the program and then you
empirically study where i had some kind
of profiling that i knew
what was important yeah so
you you don't think the supplies
generally i mean there's something that
rings true to this across i'm glad that
it applied generally but but it was it
was only my good luck
i said it but you know but but i did but
i said it in limited context and i and
and i'm glad if it
makes people think about stuff because i
i'm actually but
it applies
in another sense too that is
um
sometimes i will
do optimization in a way that does help
the
the actual running time
but makes the program impossible to
change next week
because i've changed my data structure
of something that
that made it less adaptable
so one of the great uh uh
principles of computer science is
is
it's laziness or whatever you call it
the
late binding uh you know don't
hold off decisions when you can
um
and
and and you know and we understand now
quantitatively how valuable that is
what what do you mean we understand so
you mean
people
people have written thesis about how you
can how late binding will
it will improve the i mean you know just
in time manufacturing or whatever
you can make you can defer a decision
instead of doing your advanced planning
and say i'm gonna allocate thirty
percent to this and fifty percent so in
all kinds of domains there's an
optimality to laziness in many cases the
decision is not made in advance so
instead you
you design
in order to be flexible uh uh to to
change with the uh
with the way the wind is blowing yeah
but so the reason that line resonated
with a lot of people is because
there's something about the programmer's
mind
that wants that enjoys optimization so
it's a constant struggle
to
balance
laziness and lay binding with
the desire to optimize
to that the elegance of a well-optimized
code is something that's compelling to
programming
yeah
it's
another concept of beauty
you